let's bring in Fox News contributor and
correspondent for the Washington
examiner Byron York Byron great to see
you thanks for being here so I'll get
your big 2022 midterm uh you know your
projection for the key winners uh in the
upcoming election in just a moment the
first of the top issues you just heard
Lindsey Graham there uh this is putting
obviously uh with just you know 50 plus
days out uh abortion front and center
obviously for republicans and really
dividing the party we have seen in the
wake of those comments you've got crime
you've got immigration and you've got
inflation that report last week was a
stunner I mean 8.3 inflation I mean
you've got you've got the average
American paying 13.5 grocery inflation
in this country what do you see as the
top issue for voters
yeah I I think that when this is all
over we might see last week last Tuesday
when the inflation numbers came out as a
turning point in this midterm race
because there's no doubt Democrats had
been uh moving up doing much much better
uh on a few issues the so-called generic
ballot was getting a lot closer they
pulled ahead things were looking good
for them and then these inflation
numbers told everybody that inflation
was a chronic a persistent problem not
going to go away not really very much
better the latest Fox News poll we see
if you combine the number of people who
say they are most concerned top issue
about inflation with those who are most
concerned about jobs in the economy
three really related topics you get 34
percent the number who were most
concerned about abortion is 16 less than
half that so Republicans I think are
feeling a little more confident this
week than they were a couple of weeks
ago that inflation will indeed remain
the top issue and that helps them in the
race that poll you mentioned we have on
the screen there inflation 19 they say
that is the biggest issue motivating
them as voters right now but to your
point if you if you combine that with
jobs in the economy which they're not
really separate issues
um you're pulling twice that of of those
who say abortion is their top issues
Byron all right what is your big 2022 uh
forecast
well I think the the news has is
basically what it's always been which is
the the house uh the Republicans uh are
in a very very very good position to
take the house I mean there's just no uh
doubt about it historically the issues
all of that uh it looks very good for
Republicans as far as the Senate is
concerned it's been impossible to
predict anything with the Senate
although it is true uh that a couple of
races especially Pennsylvania seem to be
getting a little closer and that means
the Republicans actually Rising a little
bit Dr Oz Rising a little bit toward
eating into the John Federman lead so
it's not impossible at all that
Republicans could win back uh the Senate
but as far as the house is concerned
looking really solid for them right now
you know uh Daryl Isa was here last week
and and making sure people who are
making those type of projections know
that even if Republicans do pull out
victories say in the house for example
the margin by which they pull off
Victory is going to be key because you
could have some of those Republicans
that do eventually pull off Victory not
supporting esta The Establishment so if
they're going to get anything done in
the house that's going to have to be a
pretty hefty margin of Victory to that
you say what Byron
no you're absolutely right look a
majority in the house is 218 seats
you're never going to get all those
people to agree on every single thing
just not going to happen so uh to to
Really effectively govern a party needs
a majority in which they can lose 5 10
maybe even a dozen more members and
still win so uh the idea you know
Republicans win the house with 219 220
seats that's barely any majority at all
it's it's better than not winning the
house but it's a really tiny tiny
majority they get 235 240 something like
that it's a much more governable
majority very interesting great to have
you on Byron great to see you thank you
so much for joining us
thank you Sandra all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else